voilà une rentrée attendue aussi c'est
avec lui que je parlais à la télévision
ce soir sur antenne 2 celle d'yves
montand yves montand dont vous allez
pouvoir voir ou à revoir le récital de
l'automne et de l'hiver à l'olympia
jeudi revoir pour ceux qui ont eu la
chance d'être là et et voir pour ceux
qui n'étaient pas parmi les deux cent
mille privilégié parce qu'on s'est
vraiment bousculés on s'est battus aux
portes de l'olympia et puis ça a
continué en province et et depuis on a
l'impression que vous n'arrêtez plus et
que vous allez vous avez redémarrer une
nouvelle carrière
non je dirais plutôt que je me suis fait
piéger agréablement piégé mais je me
suis fait piéger très sincèrement enfin
on le croire ou le crois pas donc peu
importe vous avez comme on disait
politique cédé à l'amicale pression de
vos amis ça oui c'est ça oui encore ou
quelquefois car maintenant je voudrais y
des contrats au japon aux états unis en
allemagne metropolitan opera de new york
c'est 4000 placebo coup d'arrêt j'ai pas
me plaindre parce qu'on première place
numéro bigel personnes oblige à le faire
même temps c'est excitant parce que bon
s'ils devaient le faire c'est maintenant
et pas après mais vont revenir au show
qui doit passer ce soir je crois que le
travail admirable qu'a fait notre amie
qui est difficilement le metteur en
scène les techniciens de chef opérateur
on a l'impression quand même que la
variété il faudra trouver une autre
solution
je pense que la variété les valable ou
une pièce de théâtre ou à l'opéra
comme le dit si justement monsieur roch
lieberman dans une émission c'est
valable que si c'était vraiment en
direct sur le moment même en louant par
exemple un palais des sports ou en
longue par exemple je ne sais pas mais
un grand stade et sur des écrans géants
de 2 8 ou 12 mètres de hauteur
voir par exemple d'imaginer qu'un et
rolling stone le monde veut venir au
parc des princes que je souhaiterais
vraiment vous les voyez vous même on
dirait que c'est à dire que tout d'un
coup vous avez donc la fragilité des
interprètes ou deux interprètes
homme ou femme l'insécurité est le
danger
et vous comment ces deux armées jusqu'à
z vous pouvez pas reprendre et spa
confort
quelquefois être capable de jouer un jeu
à oui mais je crois que j'ai pas le seul
parce que ça veut dire quelque chose là
c'est vous dire que jouer cette partie
là on l'a fait on a fait mais c'est
quelque chose qui repris deux fois trois
fois par un petit pont sur trois jours
on a fait le show comme tous les shows
en général naturellement comme tout des
spectacles mais je pense que c'est ça et
je crois que les gens se déplacerait
irait certainement près des sports pour
voir une attraction qu'ils aiment bien
qu'ils étaient maintenant prendre la
place plutôt que de rester devant cette
petite boîte qui malgré tout même si
c'est très bien fait et c'était très
bien de tourner par guy seligmann je
tiens à le répéter encore une fois
j'arrête dans une petite boîte
yves montand vous dites souvent du bien
des gens qui vous entourent et du monde
en général
et puis c'est vrai qu'on a eu du mal à
trouver des gens qui disent du mal de
vous vous êtes un des français les plus
populaires on a quand même trouvé
quelqu'un qui dis pas du mal de vous
mais qui dans son approche je les vois à
quelque chose qui devrait vous
interpeller c'est un chanteur comme vous
s'appelle charlélie couture
regardez ce qu'ils nous disaient qu'ils
à peu près deux mois de sa trentaine de
minutes
faux
voilà il monte un qui passe dimanche au
printemps de bourges de solidarnosc
c'est ce que c'est l'image et joue avec
ça semblait pas tellement apprécié je
m'entends charlie c'est aussi l'époque
comme mon père c'est bien documentaire
parle bien c'est bien d'avoir un peu
quelques commandes et 1 1
quelques ombres au dessus de soi qui
continuent à planer encore un collabo
quand l'oiseau est déjà haut dans le
ciel est tous assez bien vous voyez ce
qui veut dire ce que ça veut dire
je crois que ce qui me fait de la peine
c'est un petit peu qu'ils lisent qui
parle de son père j'ai très bien et ça
m'étonne pas c'est un garçon intelligent
il ya beaucoup de talents qui se servent
du racisme de là je trouve ça super on
passe à hauteur ça on sait très bien que
quand on a l'âge que j'ai bon on est
bons peuvent être mis au rancart sassus
le sait très bien je le sais j'ai pas de
changer là dessus quand j'avais 18 ans
j'avais comme de 30 32 ans était déjà
quelqu'un de et à 40 en parlons pas lé
nom là dessus mais c'est pas de faire du
racisme sur le ce qui montre le nombre
oui ce qui me fait de la peine là je dis
très sincèrement et c'est sur le fait
qu' il puisse me charrier si je puis
dire pour ont pris un peu le son terme
sur le fait de porter ce qu d'argos à la
boutonnière
mais c'est vrai que vous avez une
fidélité parce que depuis deux mois vous
ne l'avez bruit c'est pratiquement une
apathique et wii puis je voudrais dire
aussi que c'est pas du tout une question
d'un acte de courage ce même pas une
question de la provocation c'est
uniquement par fidélité à quelque chose
qui me semble qui est important mais il
est très jeune monsieur sur la couture
et verra ça plus tard
oui je crois que je crois que c'est très
important les événements qui sont
produits en pologne est quelque chose
qui ébranlera le reste du monde et en
tout cas c'est une chose qui marque et
porter ça c'est d'abord assez fidèle à
mon ami tu vas les acquis venu me voir
l'olympia comme vous le savez et
j'enlèverai le jour il sera libéré ses
amis libéré sinon je me garderai pour
uniquement rappeler aux gens quand vous
croisez un regard tiens c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu un mouvement formidable qui a fait
l'unanimité de tout le monde de toutes
tendances toute opinion quand cette
chose arbitre r bien sûr que des gens
dits de droite s'en sont servis et pour
quoi cela servirait-il pas c'est pas
tout de même
aussi n'est-ce pas une façon pas non
plus exagérer dans l'autre sens
évidemment qu'ils se servent de tous
pourrait se servir at il pas évidemment
mais c'est surtout je crois que il faut
rester fidèle à ce que j'appellerais une
forme de lutte contre la tyrannie
et ça il faut rester fidèle je suis à la
chasse et tout est un jour où les
événements vous donne un peu
tragiquement raison puisque
effectivement un mouvement qu'on croyait
un petit peu enfouis et a ressurgi ouvre
le jeu n'a à varsovie
voilà merci yves montand et donc rendez
vous tout à l'heure après la publicité
pour votre show à l'olympia